zelenski there as we heard saying that
the counter-offensive is going slower
than he would like is that the reality
it was well it's you know day 485 of
Vladimir Putin's 10-day special military
operation the Russians did what they did
always last night and they fired 10
cruise missiles kh101s and kh55s into
the west of Ukraine they're all shot
down
um but Ukraine's counter-offensive has
started it's going to be slow it's one
of those operations where it's going to
be deliberately slow and they're going
into sort of three areas just north and
south of bakmut we were talking about
bakmut all of last year
um between Donetsk and the zapparisha or
blasts or just south of Donetsk and
there's some unconfirmed reports that
they've actually broke the ukrainians
have broken through some of the Russian
defensive lines there and then through
zaparizia down to tokmak further
um in in the South as they try and get
in and they're probing at the moment
they've taken approximately 113 square
kilometers in the last couple of weeks
to put put that into context the
Russians took 18 months to get about
five kilometers in backwards so they're
not doing too badly and they're doing it
without all the resources you know when
we look at what we did in the Gulf War
we had
um 1400 aircraft that spent over 30 days
attacking the Iraqi defensive positions
before we went in the ground Ukraine is
going the ground without any of that so
that strategy from zelenski it is yeah
okay and tell us a bit more about this
attack on a Russian Bridge a Ukrainian
attack on an important Russian Bridge
well yes this was um here's a here's a
picture of of the bridge
and it was an attack by a allegedly by a
British storm travel missile which is
designed to take out this sort of level
of critical infrastructure and this
bridge itself was a very important
logistic link
um a ground line of communication
between Crimea where Russia's got an
awful lot of its resources and up into
the occupied part of Ukraine um and the
tronar bridge that's there it's so
important that again unconfirmed reports
but I have seen some good pictures of
pontoon Bridge the Russians are built
today underneath that to try and keep
that line of communication open up to
Melita Paul because if they if they
didn't if that remain closed then the
alternative route is about double the
length double the length of time and
they've got the logistic convoys exposed
to further Ukrainian artillery and then
of course we've got this uh concern
bubbling up it's been bubbling up for
for weeks months now uh on the zeparesia
power plant zelenski warning of a
potential attack we do and interestingly
put it into context you know president
zielinski warned about the attack on the
dam across the donipo river for months
beforehand and give us warnings that
have been mined and then the Russians
have blown the mines causing a massive
environmental disaster in the area the
separation nuclear power plant again
um there's been reports of the inside of
a big mind for defensive purposes you
don't put Minds inside a nuclear power
plant inside nuclear react for defensive
purposes but it shows that the Russians
are not concerned about the
environmental damage of what they're
doing so I think this is one where we
need to watch very closely and we need
to take this Potential Threat very
seriously